now here are the biggest risks when you
buy a house here are the biggest risks
number one is you could have no tenant
no tenant means no no cash flow no cash
flow means not a good deal to you you
need a ten however there's only one
thing that's worse than no ten and that
is I a bad tenant so how do we stop this
happening how do we make sure like this
house we're buying it for 50 grand or
forty five or whatever we're buying it
for no as it happens there's already a
tenant in there so it's very easy for us
to check whether that's um it's a good
tenant we can look at there how long
they've been there have they always paid
their rent on time look at the contract
and it might be that we want to buy the
house and keep it up it might be that we
want to buy the house and we're gonna
ask us listed to bought with vacant
possession to get a new tenant but it's
not so difficult but how do we make sure
like what happens if what happens if
that tenants only been in there three
months and when we buy it the tenant
moves out and then we've got no toner
and then we can't fill the property
again well what happens if we buy it we
buy it and the tenant becomes about ten
well it sounds great but then next year
the tenant moves out and then someone
else moves in who's bad how do we
prepare for that how do we risk assess
that and how do we prevent that from
happening
what happens if the house is a bad house
and how could it be a bad house but it
might be that we overpay the odds in my
lobby that we buy it for a forty at
forty five and we say yes
five grand below market value fifty
grand is not the market value
necessarily fifty grand is the asking
price actually over 50 but fifty is the
asking price then the asking price what
the definition of the asking price is
that's what they are asking for the
market value the definition of the
market value is this is the true current
market value when you're buying a house
you always need to know what the actual
value is the house might be worth fifty
five my wave six day my worth forty
a risk of being a landlord or buying a
property is that you get tripped up or
caught out by the legislation legal
responsibilities as a landlord or things
just like imagine you buy the house and
the house has got a restricted
restricted coming on which means that
you can't rent it out and now you don't
know that and you buy it and then you
find out and then you're stuffed
or there's a flying freehold issue or a
ransom strip in the garden or there is a
mineshaft under or it's got high risk of
flooding all this stuff is legal post
behind the house legal stuff could be
legal responsibilities as a landlord
EPCs difficut gas safety certificate
making sure that you register the
deposits when you move a tenant in
making sure that you know the correct
contracts to use with the tenants all
this kind of stuff now what's the risk
here the risk is that you just messed up
make a mistake buy a house that's got a
legal problem or buy a house and you
don't know your legal responsibilities
and you don't register the tenants
deposit and then the tenant ends up
suing you three times them out of the
deposit that's the kind of stuff that
can happen if you don't know the legal
and legislations so what happens if
interest rates go up now of course you
can protect against that by fixing
interest rates and here's the thing
property investing is always going to
have some risk associated because
everything in life does anyway bad
tenants get a reference from a previous
landlord now don't get a reference from
the current landlord which is what most
agents do they can all get a previous
landlord check and then they go to their
current landlord and then their current
landlord let's say they were terrible
tenant their current landlord is going
to be like oh they're amazing yeah man
have them have them having the great is
that true you've seen this I'm saving
you guys a lot of money here with this
stuff so I'm glad you appreciate it so
what you wanna do is you want to get a
reference from the previous to the
previous landlord I either actual
previous landlord why because that
landlord doesn't have an agenda it's
very
nice when you're doing business with
people that don't have an agenda or if
they do have an agenda at least tell you
their agenda but on many people you know
have an agenda and then they'll so so
you want to go to the landlord prior and
believe me they'll tell you the truth
next get a credit check on the on the on
the tenant now it's credit checks
sometimes are so hardcore that even if
they had a ten-pound mobile phone late
payment one month because they are
moving banks three years later will
still be flagging you up saying their
credit they're not passed the credit
score so what I do is I get a credit
check but then I'll be gracious
depending on how bad their credit is if
they've got county court judgments and
they've not paid their rent in the past
the landlords and then I'm not
interested but if they've got a good
reference if they're in a job they can
afford it you can do an affordability
check then that's the kind of things
you're looking for if the house gets
trashed what really happens is the
tenants move in and they have pets and
their kids draw on the walls and they
leave the shower windows closed and it
steams up in them begins to get mold and
they cook all greasy and they're and
they just live a different way than you
and I would live and the house begins to
deteriorate a little bit and the carpets
get messy and they don't clean it and
they don't clean up the kitchen ever and
it's just a bit yeah and things break
and they don't report it and then after
five years they move out and then you go
around and you go holy come early
they've trashed this place
I've got trashed it you have to been
five ground or ten ground depending on
how bad it is so here's what you did to
get around there again inventory and
then after three months with the tenant
living there get the management company
to go and do an inspection on the
property if the tenant doesn't want
there to be inspections and they're all
uncomfortable about it it's red flags
you know it's like well why what are you
doing what's so important that every six
months the agent can't arrange to pop
over for twenty minutes or ten minutes
so you want it but here's the thing do
you do all this
no who does this your management company
there's there's this bad and then
there's really bad so bad would be
things like a leaky roof
electrics need repair in boiler needs
repair in that's bad biggie biggie
between bad and really bad would be
theirs damp and they've just tiled over
the damp but then when you buy the house
three mums
later it starts cracking and instantly
you gotta spend thousands of pounds
getting this dam fixed or all really bad
would be that there's like something
structurally wrong with the house the
serious cracks but then that should be
picked up on a mortgage valuation how do
you stop this happening when I'm gonna
show you how to veil your house very
simple just get a survey there's
different types of surveys you can get I
would recommend getting something called
an independent building survey that will
only cost you about three four hundred
pounds and it just gives you that
assurance that when you're buying a
house that the house is legit because
what they'll did by the way is it
important to see the house and view it
before you buy it yes or no it's
actually not most of my houses I'm
building six houses from scratch of
course I won't see them before they're
built but I guess that's the time it
different but I didn't even see the land
and look at the land I didn't look at
the castle I didn't see the castle until
after we'd we'd bought it at auction I
don't even see it most of the houses
that I buy I don't see them first but
you know what why it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter because the surveyor sees
it and who's more competent than
qualified to check if the houses got any
problems me or the surveyor surveyor as
great as I think I am the surveyors
going to go around with all these fancy
equipment he's got all this special
stuff to be able to tell what's behind
the walls he's very experienced he does
it full-time for a living he's going to
look at stuff that I wouldn't want to
look out like go up to the roof and you
know he's gonna do a really good
inspection he'll be there for hours and
I'd rather pay him 350 pounds not only
will it save me doing it but he'll do a
better job than I would and if there's
anything that he is like risky like he's
like sure about this he'll then flag it
up and tell me and I'll get a special
specialist to go in and do it under the
survey just in my area so get an
independent building survey because the
last thing you want to do is buy a house
it's got a little leak in the roof you
weren't aware of it and then three
months later it's causing problems and
it's going to cost thousands of pounds
to fix it like it's just not what you
want alright legal rules very simple
depending on the rule change like
sometimes the rule change will only
affect you down the line like later
Alistair's going to be
talking about HMOs and article four and
things like that and if the rules change
it only affects new people not old
people but even if it does we've rule
changes then we just I'm gonna I'm gonna
just put this out there okay now just to
stop anyone being shocked down the line
okay the rules will change what works
today won't work in ten years how do I
know that because ten years ago this
stuff I was doing I'm doing different
stuff now so how do we come up with that
well what we do is with fluid investors
we change strategy we adapt different
because things change so the rules will
change but here's what you got to
remember as I said this morning the
people that make the rules are the same
people that make money in property so
you just need to be like okay the rules
changed if it's affected me negatively
how can I
it's like advantage of this like I said
before Jim Rohn says the same wind blows
on us all
but that doesn't determine the
destination what determines the
destination is the way you set the sail
so the wind is just the rules the wind
is just the economy but when you learn
to create your own economy
what creating your own economy really
means is it just means figuring out how
to maximize off of the wrong changes so
the tax change is brexit legislation all
these changes I'm extremely happy about
and I'm embracing and I'm getting very
wealthy off the back of it in five years
or ten years there'll be more changes I
guess the biggest risk bigger than all
of these is not like no tenor nor but a
bad house the absolute biggest risk is
actually no house and how is that going
to happen
that's gonna come happen by just not
taking any action you know that's when I
look back over the last 11 years of
investing in property I've not lost much
money investing in property I haven't
I've made a lot money but I've not lost
much money there's no this may be one
property that's kind of broke even
annoyingly but there's no properties
where I'm just like I lost so much on
that deal so I've done quite well
luckily I got educated
good people around me but I have lost
money by not buying properties I should
have bought I look back and I'm like oh
my gosh I almost bought it but I didn't
because I thought it was too risky but
now that properties tripled in value
it's lost like 300 grand because I
didn't buy it so the biggest risk
[Music]